Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are going to be talking about
the things that scare us the most.
Why is it that we only get
to be scared in October?
I don't know the way culture works,
but apparently if you're in the business
of being scared, you gotta
talk about it in October.
But man, you know,
there's a holiday at the end of the month
and it's called Reformation Day.
Reformation Day.
I mean, Halloween.
Yep.
You know, yeah.
It's that time of year where-
People need routine people.
I understand.
If you're one of those people
who is like a little strange,
and like has something deep inside of you
that's like a seed of darkness
that at any moment could explode
into like some sort of tree-
You think this is strange.
This is all people, man.
It's just some of us embrace it.
Somebody who hasn't, like,
who's not too religious, who's like,
"Oh, this is my favorite
time of year," you know.
This is for you, peeps.
Love ya.
Okay, first of all, let me just,
I feel like there was some
exclusionary language there,
so I wanna backtrack
over some of that stuff.
The first thing being that-
I want to other you.
A little bit weird,
calling these people a little bit weird.
Incidentally, I just recently saw
in some stats that-
People who like horror movies.
That were presented at
the YouTube Summit that-
We can't shut up about it.
I think more than half of.
I think it might be like the most popular
subgenre of movies right now
amongst the general public.
Also, I think that everyone
has a seed of darkness inside of them,
some people have just
made friends with it.
Hence Reformation Day.
And then, what was the last thing you said
that was exclusionary?
Oh, not religious.
Not religious.
Actually, I have always
been a fan of horror movies,
and actually, one of the
things I'm gonna talk about,
I think my religious
past plays into the way
that I think about it.
And some of the people that I know
who are still very, very religious
consider themselves, very,
very big horror fans,
because I think it makes it
that much more visceral and real.
I'm just messing, you know.
Some of the nicest, sweetest people
I know are horror fanatics.
Because they get it out,
just like some of the nicest,
sweetest people I know
are really hardcore heavy metal fans,
because-
Interesting.
When you've got a form of entertainment
that is a release-
A release.
Like if you're into screamo
or you're into like hard
death metal, you know,
the traditional understanding of that
culturally is to be
scared of these people.
Putting a hole in your like body
and then stretching it real far.
Yeah, people who do that kind of stuff,
in my experience, tend to be the sweetest,
most well adjusted people
because they've, again,
they've made friends with
that side of themselves.
It's like everybody's got it in it.
He's the nicest person I know.
He must have a penile piercing.
Yeah, those of us who have denied that
that is a part of us,
it's just sitting there
and it has its way with us.
We don't control it.
You need to make friends with it
so you can control it.
It's in there, if you
don't make friends with it,
it controls you.
It's like having a pet or having like-
A gremlin.
A predator
that lives with you.
Yeah, it's like a Mogwai or a gremlin.
Yeah, learn to embrace it.
Which I was too afraid to watch, always.
That's what basically, ultimately,
Link, what I'm getting at here,
what I'm implying is that-
You have yet to-
Oh, I know what
you're implying.
Make friends with
the dark seed inside of you.
I think-
And it makes you
a little unpredictable
and potentially a serial killer.
I've made a list.
That's the number one thing, you know.
You've made your list,
I've made my list of the things
that scare us the most.
I guess I should put the number one thing
on my list is that my
doom seed will germinate.
Like what's gonna happen?
Yeah.
You know-
'Cause everybody's got one.
Also know I have this
side of me that like,
that can be impulsive and not, you know.
I thought about putting that on the list.
Am I afraid of myself?
Everybody should be a little bit.
Yeah.
Everybody has within them the potential
to one day have a psychotic break
and run down the street naked.
Everyone has the potential for that.
Right, if you have a psych,
then you could have a psychotic break.
And my belief is if you
are a heavy metal fan,
you are the least likely
to be the one running
naked down the street.
That's just my anecdotal theory.
Channel it. Release it.
What do you think about that, Jenna?
Just, I know plenty of metal people
and I mean, I've seen them run down naked.
Running naked down the
street intentionally
or as a result of a psychotic break?
I'm just saying these
are different things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Probably it's intentionally.
Yeah, right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's nothing wrong with streaking.
Yeah.
In fact, I'm an advocate.
Yeah, I'm due for a good streak.
Do you know that-
I need to get struck.
I'm not gonna name any names here,
but somebody that I know-
Bob.
Who is currently in college,
I was recently talking to them.
It's not my son, just in
case you're wondering.
And there's a tradition-
My daughter.
No.
I'm not gonna let you narrow it down,
but it's not either one of our kids.
But there is a tradition at
many schools of streaking.
There's an area of a campus
where there is a tradition of streaking,
like you run from here to here.
And I was on the phone talking to him
and he was telling me about, well yeah.
I was like, "What'd you do
to celebrate your birthday?"
He was like, "Well, we went streaking."
That's great.
You know, and again, it's just like,
that's something you do,
and when it's intentional
and it's not the result
of a psychotic break,
that's a different,
it's a different story.
Yeah. Yeah.
You know, I don't.
Yeah, I was about to mention names,
but I won't go in that direction.
I was gonna make fun of a
certain country music singer,
but I like the person.
I don't wanna make fun of him.
Oh, I know who you're talking about.
So instead I'll say, yeah, actually,
Lily in her freshman year,
you know, very early on,
she reported that there
was a streaking cavalcade.
I think it's important.
But she didn't participate as a freshman,
but hey, she's a sophomore now, you know.
Well, incidentally, in the footage
that you uncovered from our college days
that we showed some of that
on the Mythical Society-
Never before seen scenes.
One of the videos
me and Greg streaking,
not in any like place on campus,
but in our apartment complex.
From the apartment.
I said, "If you guys will strip down naked
and let me film you streaking,
then I will join you
guys in shaving my head."
And then I was shocked
to watch the footage
because we did not try to frame it
in such a way as to not
show any junk flailing.
Yeah.
And when I say we, I guess I mean me,
'cause I was filming.
And so I was like, oh my God,
I can't give this to employees to edit.
Yeah, right.
There's junk flailing.
Yeah, it's pretty blurry.
Yeah.
I pride myself on having unblurry junk,
but I was not streaking at the time.
It was not-
I have very crisp junk.
It was 1996 and you were
using a handheld DV,
and it's like the footage is 20 years old.
So what do we wanna do?
Let's get into this.
Get into the fears.
'Cause I like it when we
each have made our list
and we can surprise each other.
This is more your jam,
so you should go first.
I'm gonna start-
What scares you most?
I'm kind of starting
in more expected
territory with demons and-
Okay. All right.
Again, it is amazing how, first of all,
they just keep putting out horror movies.
And my experience with horror movies
is I go to watch horror
movies now with Shepherd,
'cause he's the one that
will watch 'em with me.
Jessie won't.
We go to the theater quite a bit,
and we'll watch a horror movie,
most recently "Barbarian,"
which I wrecked 'cause I loved it.
And if you go see a horror movie,
especially if you go to an AMC Theater,
what do they do before the horror movie?
They show you 15 trailers, right?
Of other horror movies.
So every horror movie that's coming out.
And then my typical experience is,
because I tend to then go
to Rotten Tomatoes to see,
is this worth my time?
Is this worth me and my son's time?
Is that eight times outta 10,
which would also be four times outta five,
they're so low ranked.
Like these horror movies end up
being in the teens sometime.
And you're like, man,
that looked like it was gonna be so great.
But the trailers really get you
in the mood to be scared, right?
And I find myself consistently frightened
by the exorcism ones.
And I'm not talking about "The Exorcist,"
I'm talking about-
All of 'em.
So there's a movie,
I don't know what the name of it is.
It's probably out now by the time
we're talking about this.
But they've been rolling the trailers
and it's about this nun
who is like studying.
You basically get the
whole movie in the trailer.
But she's studying exorcism
amongst these males.
It's a men only like priesthood,
Catholic priesthood training,
and then it let her in to this class,
not because she's gonna be a priest,
but because she's doing.
I don't know what the premise is,
but she's in this class.
Oh yeah, "Glass Ceiling."
'Cause, see, I went to
the Jordan Peele movie
and I saw this trailer too.
Yeah and-
She's the only one who can do it.
And then there's like this thing
where her mother was a bit nuts
and it turns out, well,
her mother wasn't nuts,
her mother was possessed.
And this demon has been trying
to get into her for all this time,
and it's in this little girl
that they've got in the
bottom of this like church.
The scenes are just chilling to the bone,
and first of all, they
do the classic thing,
which has always scared me,
is anytime you pair anything like scary
and supernatural with a little girl.
I thought that was gonna
be a separate thing on the list.
Scared of little girls.
You telling me that little
girls is not on your list?
Little girls who are possessed by demons.
So that is inclusive of-
Well that's-
And again, this is probably
some unresolved misogyny or whatever.
You see this little girl and you're like,
oh, she's not a threat.
She couldn't do anything to hurt anyone.
And then, but when the
devil gets inside of her
and she puts on a little dress
and her head starts spinning around.
It just, it gets me,
and I am so frightened by it.
So you're really saying demon girls,
demon possessed girls.
You're not just talking about demons.
But I mean, it's scary when
they go into dudes too,
man, it's just not as scary.
Okay, okay, I get it.
But let's go there.
I wanna come back to demons in general,
but let's keep going down this path.
So you're gonna see that movie?
Well, I'm gonna look
at the Rotten Tomatoes
and see if it's any good.
I remember back in the day-
I bet you it sucks.
You got me to see "The Ring" with you.
"The Ring's" good.
There's a girl in that.
Well, and Jessie and I had that co-dream
that I talked about on the podcast.
I talked about it on "GMM."
I had to go back and listen to that
to really get the details,
but then I have since not
gone back and listened to it.
But essentially, there was
a little girl in a dream.
In my dream, a nightmare, and I woke up,
this little blonde girl,
and then Jessie woke up
from a nightmare and she had been dreaming
about a little blonde girl,
and I swear that we had
some little demon in our dreams, man.
Now, here's the thing.
What do I actually believe about this?
Let's go there because-
Right 'cause I thought that-
That's the deeper question.
When you said demons, I was like, well,
I was presuming that
what you were going with here was like,
these scare me the most in movies,
like possessions and stuff like that,
because you know, it could be real.
The spiritual realm, demons, possessions.
This stuff could be real.
That's what makes it real scary.
Yeah, and I think that's
what really ingrained it
in my mind as a kid
was seeing "The Exorcist"
trailer when I was.
I remember "The Exorcist" trailer-
"Exorcist."
Coming on while I was watching television,
and I felt like I had
to get out of the room.
You know, I was like,
oh, no, no, no, no, no.
It was overwhelming.
And because at that point-
Hey, don't come through the TV, man.
At that point, there was absolutely
no question in my mind that
this stuff is real, right.
It was like, of course demons are real.
Now, we were in like a
Baptist church at the time
where it's like nobody's
getting possessed.
I mean, maybe somebody's
got like a demon of gluttony
or something 'cause they're
going to the buffet too much.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the way that but it's-
How many times has he gone back
to the church potluck table?
It's not, there's not in the same way
that there is in like a
Pentecostal or a Charismatic.
Now, when I did go and work
with Campus Crusade in New York City
for the summer of 1998,
we worked with exclusively
Charismatic churches.
So these are mostly Black churches
who are doing the inner
city work up there,
and I did witness an exorcism.
Well, there was an
exorcism in the next room.
Whoa.
Like a lot of like yelling
and screaming and then like
a girl went into a room,
there was some yelling and screaming-
Was this during a service?
Yeah, yeah.
So there was, you said it was a girl?
Yeah, but she wasn't a little girl-
Or a woman?
She was a teen.
Okay, it was a teen.
Yeah, not quite as scary
as a little girl.
She was in the service.
Was she brought forward as this teen
needs to be exorcized.
We got,
we were working at the church.
Put her on the Peloton.
So it wasn't that simple.
We arrived as it was in process,
and we heard stuff going on and then like,
she kind of walks out and she
looks like she's been crying,
which again-
Oh wow.
My personal, at the time,
let me just be honest with you.
At the time I thought, nah, that's .
That's not a demon.
That's what I thought at the time,
because I was like, dude,
I've seen the demons in the movie, man.
She's not spitting peas.
Her voice didn't change.
And since then-
Spitting peas, is that what happened?
Well, anything you eat, you gotta.
In "The Exorcist," she spit.
I mean, it's green.
I don't know if it was peas,
I can't really remember.
Oh, you're talking about vomit.
Yeah.
But clearly supernatural things happen,
that's what makes it super scary.
However, I have watched many exorcisms
on YouTube because I'm
kind of into it and-
Really?
There's a guy in South America
who is pretty famous for doing exorcisms,
and there's a British YouTuber,
I can't remember his name-
What?
Who went down there to investigate.
I told you about this.
When do you, yeah, when you
tell me stuff like this,
I act like I'm listening,
but I'm going into flight mode.
Okay, great.
Or freeze mode.
I'm not-
Well, here's the thing-
I can't listen to this.
There's nothing
to be scared of.
There's also that-
Are you, can you describe
what this situation is
when you're watching this?
Are you like in a doctor's
office waiting room
just watching exorcisms before you go back
to get your mole checked?
No-
Are you like turning
all the lights off
in like your basement?
Well, to be clear, I don't
watch exorcism content
on the internet to be scared,
because it is definitively not scary.
What's it like?
It's fake.
Oh. Oh.
Okay.
That's the point I've been trying
to get to this whole time is that-
No, but there's plenty of exorcisms
that even if it's not real-
There is no exorcism-
It seems-
There is no exorcism
that has ever been recorded on video
that anyone is doing anything
that a normal person couldn't
do, just acting weird.
And that's why there's no evidence
that any of this stuff is real,
as far as I've never seen
any evidence that it's real.
Yeah but the girl who
came out of the room,
do you think she was an actor
at that church you went to?
No, she was being emotionally manipulated.
That's horrible.
Well, is it really?
I mean-
Well, yeah.
It it, it is-
She-
Hold on, hold on.
What do you mean?
It is horrible,
but I'm saying emotional manipulation
happens in almost every group of people
that you can possibly come up with.
Right?
I'm doing it to you right now.
It can be more intense,
and I do think that
there's spiritual abuse
that happens in that.
What I'm saying is that it's a charade
that everyone is in on
and everyone believes.
It's not dishonest.
I think that that girl
thought she was possessed-
Oh, okay.
And I think that
these preachers who were doing it
thought that she was possessed.
It's not an act.
That's what you believe
about speaking in tongues.
Yes.
Okay, okay, yeah.
I know people
who are Charismatic Christians
who could speak in tongues,
no longer believe in Christianity
and still can speak in tongues because-
Right.
It is, the human body is amazing.
The stuff that we can do.
Our mind is so flexible.
We can convince ourselves.
We can hold two disparate
thoughts at the same time.
I'm not surprised at all
about any supernatural experiences
that people claim to have had,
and I'm still open to the
fact that they might be real,
and that's why it's still scary to me
'cause I'm like, well, it might be real.
And there's always gonna be a part of me
that's like, it might be real.
I'm just saying that
I've never seen anything
that would suggest that
there is stuff actually happening
that can't just be explained
by people's mind playing tricks on 'em.
But hey, I'm open to it.
I'm still looking into it.
And that's why I watch,
I'm just fascinated with
religious culture in general.
That's why I watch a lot
of preachers on YouTube,
and these guys who are exercising people,
they're the most entertaining of all.
There's one guy, is the name Bob?
Bob something, and he's got a cross
and he puts it on your forehead
and he's got a Bible,
and it's like, this dude
is freaking intense.
And again, everybody
thinks that it's real.
Bob probably knows that it's
at least somewhat deceptive,
but at this point, he's in too deep.
All right.
Wanna give a shout out
to Stevie's podcast.
It's back for season three,
"Best Friends Back, Alright!"
With her high school
best friend, Neagheen.
They've reconnected.
Now they talk about all sorts of things,
and I'm very excited about the fact that,
Stevie is going in,
well, for her birthday,
she's gonna be opening a time capsule.
I don't know when it's from.
I'm guessing it's from like grade school.
She made it in grade school.
She's gonna open it and go
through it on the podcast.
Yes.
So yeah, they've expanded.
They've bring people-
Might be a demon in there.
Might be a demon in there-
'Cause she was a little
girl when she made it.
So yeah, I love that idea.
Watch that episode or listen to,
well, listen to it along with us,
wherever you listen to your podcasts.
"Best Friends Back."
"Alright!"
Yeah.
Shout out to Neagheen.
Okay, what do you got?
Maybe she's got a time capsule too.
Well, don't look at my list.
I can't read it from here.
I need glasses.
Because this,
I was making notes
like when I was in the car
and I didn't have time
to pull up a new note.
So this is my note with my
potential DJ names on it,
and I don't want you to see 'em.
Oh, wow.
'Cause I-
I'm excited about that.
I have decided that I am
revealing my DJ persona,
including my DJ name at MythiCon.
And I'm making a list and,
you know, I will say the
first name on the list is-
Don't, don't, don't, don't read it.
I'm not gonna use it.
I'm not gonna use DJ Dope Nuts.
I'm just not gonna do that.
Sometimes you gotta just
get through some names.
Right.
To get to others.
You know, a list is kind
of like no bad ideas
until you've read 'em back.
That's the first one on the list?
That's actually the first one.
DJ Dope Nuts?
Dope Nuts, yeah.
Nuts with a Z.
Nuts with two Ts.
No but that.
Two Ts and a Z might do it.
I don't want to do anything
with an alternate spelling.
That's one of the things
that I've decided.
So I'm doing a DJ set at MythiCon.
If that's what's gonna
put you over the edge
to buy a ticket to MythiCon.
October, what is it?
29th, 30th.
And 28th and 29th.
28th and 29ths, go to MythiContickets.com.
You can experience, along
with everything else,
the dance party that I will
be DJing as my DJ persona.
We're kind of bookending MythiCon.
James and the Shame is doing
something on the first night,
and then you're closing out
basically the dance party with-
I do have dope nuts.
Whatever the DJ.
I'm excited.
I'm kind of thinking-
I don't wanna,
I don't wanna build it up too much 'cause-
No, you should, because that's how people
get excited about things.
Right.
MythiCon tickets, if
we're gonna, you know,
we're reaching capacity.
And you know what, if you can't make it,
we're gonna live stream,
we've told you this,
we're gonna live stream our stage show.
But we're not live streaming DJ Dope Nuts.
Nope.
Or James and the shame.
It's not gonna be Dope Nuts.
Don't call me that.
I'm using it-
I'm using it as-
That's not me.
As a placeholder name.
DJ TBD.
It's better than. Oh.
Call me that.
DJ TBD.
For me.
Hold on, I mean-
Or just TBD DJ.
Well, how does this relate to your fears?
Well, the first one that, it's just,
I made the list for the things
I'm afraid of under my DJ name list.
Oh.
That's what it has to do with it, homie.
Okay, I thought, okay.
Homie.
I thought you were
afraid of dope nuts.
No.
Dangling dope nuts.
That might be my first, I don't know,
DJs don't release like mixed tapes.
Maybe they do.
Who cares?
You make the rules, man.
Who cares? Yeah.
You know, it's a lot
of licensing involved.
I mean, I gotta go with
the most obvious thing
that I'm afraid of at first, blood.
I mean, I'm simply afraid of blood,
but it's not like, yes,
I'm afraid of the circulation of blood,
the concept of blood circulating.
I'm afraid of getting, like if I try
to take my own pulse, I just hate that.
I mean, and it's kind of ironic
because it's kind of the sign of life.
It's a really good sign that
there's a liquid coursing
through tubes in your body.
But when I touch it and like it pulses
and just, it makes me quease.
I just get queased.
Once the blood starts coming out,
you're also queasy, right?
Because I think that's the most,
that's the place where most
people begin to say, okay.
But like, if your finger was bleeding,
I wouldn't faint.
But if it was the result of a cut that-
If it was squirting blood.
Is the circulation is
worse than the bleeding?
Just the sight of blood,
it needs to be paired with something,
like a visceral injury-
Like a good Chianti?
No, it's like an injury or circulation.
Like it has to be paired with something.
It's the one, two punch of this blood
is associated with this thing,
this movement through my innards.
Like, I don't like anything
related to surgery,
like cutting people open,
exposing the insides,
putting the insides on the outside.
That's gross.
I think that's why I
don't like dog erections,
now that I think about it.
Because it looks like the
inside coming outside.
Yes.
I don't think many people,
I don't even think dogs
like dog erections.
Oh, they do. They do.
Then why do they lick it?
I think they're ashamed.
I didn't mean to go down this path.
I'm sorry.
Of course there's the timeless story
of me opening the Barbie doll at Christmas
and cutting my finger,
and then at my father-in-law's house,
the in-law's house and then
running to the kitchen sink.
And then the next thing I know,
I'm coming to in my
father-in-law's arms because-
It was your hand.
My finger was cut.
And like having, like
creating that crevice,
that ditch that like,
oh, how deep is that?
You mean cut?
If you see a bone, oh my gosh.
Oh, I can't stand it.
And like, so yes, seeing gross
like that in a movie is
just, it just seems nasty.
I don't like that stuff in a movie.
And then I don't like, you know,
I don't like seeing it
in medical dramas either,
like, I gotta freaking turn.
By the way-
Turn around.
I'm a huge horror fan,
but I don't think I've ever watched
like "Final Destination," right?
You know, which is just people dying
in a bunch of weird ways.
I kind of get it and I
would, if you asked me to go,
I'll go to it and I'm not
gonna get freaked out.
You're more psychological.
But yeah, I don't like, gory is not,
like I wasn't a kid that
saw those gore magazines.
What's the name?
What's that one that was always
in every stand in every
gas station we went to?
"Jugs."
No, that was different.
Anyway, I am not into that at all.
I think most people would
agree with you on this,
'cause every time, sometimes
you meet like a doctor,
an emergency room doctor especially,
and they just don't find
any of this stuff gross,
and they-
Yeah, right.
Those are the people that we need.
I can understand-
We need those people.
How you can get to that point
or be at that point where it's like,
hey, you know what, some
people might find, you know,
everybody can find
something scary or gross.
It's like, oh, look at this like black,
like furry material coming through
my epidermis on my forearm.
Oh my gosh.
That is just horrible.
Not that gross.
To somebody, it might be.
But it's an exposure thing.
I think a lot of medical students,
the first time they see a cadaver,
the first time they
slice open a human body,
the first time they're
in surgery for real.
I think you get a tolerance.
Oh my God.
I mean,
not everybody just starts.
What, I freaking deleted my entire list.
What?
Oh my God.
Is that a fear of yours?
What the hell?
How did you do that?
I just deleted my freaking DJ name list
with all of my scary .
What?
Shake it and then hit undo.
Shake it.
Yeah.
What do you mean, hit undo?
Undo.
Hold on, I saw a capital P.
Yeah, now shake it again.
And undo again.
No, now it says redo.
Redo.
There's a P.
Oh, man.
What was the P for?
Oh, did you highlight
everything while talking
and then type over it?
I think when I sneezed, I
deleted my DJ name list.
Well, maybe they were not important.
I think-
Well, I can remember one,
DJ Dope Nuts.
Oh, like what I remember.
I mean-
Oh my God!
All right, DJ Dope Nuts in the house.
I don't wanna.
Maybe it's fate.
Maybe I have to call
myself DJ Dope Nuts now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, we also have TBDJ.
TBD.
TBDJ.
Now, this is in Notes, huh?
Is it in your Notes app?
It's in Notes app,
and it's in airplane mode right now.
Oh, great, great, great.
Go. Okay, okay, okay.
Stop right now.
Take it off airplane mode.
No, no, no!
No!
No, this is exactly the kind
of thing that you would do.
I'm sweating, man-
Go get your laptop right now.
Copy the note into a new note.
Yes.
Call it something different.
I'm not gonna do it right now.
And then-
It'll be okay.
Oh, you're saying so I'll have the rest-
I guarantee-
'Cause I need to know what I'm afraid of.
I'm 100% sure that as soon
as this podcast is over,
because you're a creature of habit,
you're gonna take your
phone out of airplane mode
and you will forget.
I guarantee you there's a 100% chance
you're gonna screw this up
if you don't listen to me right now.
Maybe I should just call myself DJ P.
That's the only thing on
this freaking note now.
You need to go get your laptop,
'cause you also need it
'cause you've got your list of fears.
You don't remember all of 'em.
Can you go on without me?
Yeah, well, I think I can handle it.
You know what?
Screw you.
Screw you, man.
Well, you're the one who actually-
Let's try that again.
You're the one-
I'm gonna get you your laptop.
Can you go on without me?
Okay, here we go.
I'm gonna get your laptop.
Jenna is gonna get it.
Can you go on without me?
I doubt it, man.
I doubt it.
I really doubt it.
I really.
What's your level of
certainty that you doubt it?
I have, you know, I'm very unsure.
You know, I'm afraid.
I'm afraid of going on without you.
That's one of my top fears.
Man.
Okay, let's see if this works, guys.
This is happening.
This is my fear, man.
You know, you work so hard on something-
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you're like,
you work on a document-
And then you sneeze.
You work on a document
and then it doesn't save,
and if you're like using
Google Docs or something,
it's constantly saving.
That's the best thing
about using the cloud.
And look, I'm proving it right now.
Well, the thing about
Notes, unlike Google Docs,
if you did this on Google Docs,
you could just bring
up a previous version,
but Notes doesn't have that.
I don't know if you should put
important things in Notes.
And I was using Evernote,
and then Evernote was trying to sell me
on all this other crap, I'm like I'm not-
Evernote has previous versions.
I'm not paying Evernote
for something that-
Evernote's constantly creating
multiple notes of my notes because-
Wait, this is-
That's my thing about-
Stickies aren't notes.
I've never opened Notes on my computer.
Well, hold on.
You've never opened
Notes on your computer?
Oh, this might be trouble.
You only use stickies?
Welcome to Notes.
You don't use Notes.
Notes are way different than stickies.
I use it on my phone.
So now it's gonna go and try to sync.
It's syncing right now, guys.
Yeah, but what's it syncing with?
You've never opened Notes,
so it's not on here, bro.
It'll be on the cloud.
So go to all cloud.
All iCloud.
I don't think I'm logged in as my.
Is this the best podcast ever?
This is dramatic.
Stick with me.
This is a fear for some people.
If you believe that we
can get through this-
Right, yeah, so do it.
So what do you need to do?
I need to figure out how I'm logged in-
Well, hold on.
To the Notes app.
What folder are you?
Are you on just on my phone?
Here we go.
I'm in my iCloud account
and I'm looking at my
notes and it's not there.
Okay, so that's the iCloud
account that's on there,
so that's not your primary iCloud account.
You need to go to your
Mac address iCloud account
and it'll have 'em.
So this one's the Gmail.
And if it doesn't, you really are screwed.
You're gonna have to just
start from scratch, man.
This is the Gmail.
DJ Scratch, that could work.
I'm sure that's been taken.
All right.
So now I'm gonna sign in
with my other account.
Man, this is the most adventure
we've had on this podcast
in quite some time.
Someone's yelling at
their computer right now
of what we should do, I'm sure.
Well, if it wasn't synced to begin with,
it could be difficult at this point.
Yeah but his phone should
have been syncing with it,
'cause it says iCloud
and he's got multiple notes in there.
I just don't know why,
I think the computer for
some reason is not synced.
Here we go.
I'm in my other iCloud account.
All right, all right, here we go.
This is gonna be it.
I'm clicking on Notes.
Yes!
DJ names!
DJ Dope Nuts is back, baby.
Okay, now-
DJ TBD.
Create a new note.
And don't read these.
I'm not reading it.
Don't read my DJ names.
Create a new note and just copy it over.
I don't smell great anymore.
The stress sweats is real.
Ooh!
Yeah, I smell.
More the right pit than the left pit.
Now again, and before you start-
Turns out I'm pretty scared of this.
Okay, listen, before you
start referencing this,
create a new note and copy it over.
You have to do that first,
or the same thing-
Copy.
No, no, create a new note first.
Well, I'm gonna.
Okay, let's not panic.
Okay, I'm not, I'm just trying to-
Paste.
DJ Names Too is what I suggest.
And I would do too 'cause it's cool.
DJ Names Too.
Yes.
There we go.
Crisis averted.
Oh my gosh, guys,
thank you for hanging with me.
I wanna let you know that
I just lost six months off my life.
And now I'm reading the list of DJ names
and I don't think any of 'em
were worth the trouble.
But let's hear your next-
Like I just don't think-
Are we on your next fear
or have you finished with your fear?
I just don't think DJ
Cheese Prophet is gonna,
it was worth all this trouble.
When did this list happen, last night?
Yeah, last night.
You know, it's just kind
of like, I don't know.
Hey, what do you think?
I mean-
You know what,
I don't wanna know.
I think Profit Cheese
with no DJ could be cool.
Yeah, I'm working within the realm
of not using the term-
Term DJ.
Term DJ at all.
What, yeah, it's 2022, man, yes.
I just want to have a moniker.
Yeah, 'cause I mean, it
stands for a disc jockey.
That's the dumbest thing I've ever heard.
Well, now that this is here,
I'm just gonna use this.
All right, y'all, we're back in this.
I'm afraid of blood.
I'm afraid of injuries.
Let's move on to your
next one on the list.
Okay.
Whew.
You shake your phone and
then that's a way to undo.
How long has that been a feature?
A while.
Oh, okay. Man.
A couple of years.
As long as disc jockeys have existed.
I am afraid of medium sized groups.
Okay.
Are you talking about as a person?
Is this like, I don't think
you're talking as like social anxiety.
I think you're talking about, like,
are you talking about in a performance?
I think it's social anxiety.
Oh, okay.
'Cause I definitely know
if you're performing,
if you're like addressing a group,
a small group or a really
large group, it's easy.
But when you're addressing an awkwardly
medium sized group from like a stage,
then that's nightmarish.
And I don't, stages are
very comforting to me, so-
Separation.
You know, I'm nervous
before a stage performance.
The nervousness melts away completely
as soon as I'm on the stage
and in front of the crowd.
That's when all of the anxiety goes away.
And I'm like, now I'm here.
I'm doing what I'm supposed to do.
And of course, when it's like,
I'm going out to dinner.
There's six people or eight people
in this group of friends
and we're all having dinner together.
I'm very comfortable there.
But if it's just like, okay, 16 people
and now it's like, okay,
we're gonna go around the group.
Oh!
We're gonna go around the group
and we'd like everybody to talk about
the last time they really felt insecure,
or any, I mean, any kind of question
where it's like, okay, now I've got-
What kind of parties are you going to?
Yeah, I mean, that's
never actually happened.
I'm just imagining.
And then you have to,
it's just this weird in between social-
A lot of our fears are
things that never happen.
No, but this has happened.
I mean, there was a moment there,
where we were, pre-pandemic,
where the people that,
and this is kind of an LA thing-
Intentional friendship communities.
Yes, and like you might find, like,
I went to a Thanksgiving thing.
Oh, I don't wanna hear about that again.
I've heard about it too many times.
But no, but there was a let's go around
the horn and say something.
And it's not like it is at
Mama Di and Daddy Mac's house
when you go around the horn
and say what you're thankful for.
That's, I mean, I'm not-
This is like, you don't know, yeah.
Like, I don't know you, man.
So, you're saying it's at least 16 people
and it has to be comprised
of strangers, you know.
What, at least 50% strangers?
I think that that's part of it.
And I think that, let me-
Even if you're not doing a circle share,
let's just say-
Real circle share.
I mean, are you afraid
if it's just a mingle party?
Okay, I've never thought about this.
I'm thinking about it out loud,
so help me process this.
I think that this is the problem for me.
I have essentially two modes, right?
I'm like a robot with two modes.
This model has two modes.
Okay.
And one mode is, I'm amongst friends
and it's a small group.
And then the other mode is,
I am in front of a crowd
and I am performing.
And I think most of my
friends would be like,
"Those are two very different people."
I'm not, like, I don't,
if I'm hanging out in a small group,
I don't draw a lot of attention to myself.
I don't like start making
jokes and like do funny things.
I just, it's never been
my personality to do that.
Now, occasionally if I'm like,
somebody asks me to tell a story
or I've got something I
really want to tell y'all,
I'll kind of go into like a little bit
of the performance mode.
But I'm very rarely in
performance mode or like,
oh, I'm gonna throw.
My dad on the other hand is like,
if he's in a small group,
he's like throwing out one-liners,
making jokes all the time.
I make jokes and do one-liners
when me and you are doing
comedy together on this podcast,
on "Good Mythical Morning"
in front of a big group,
and that is very much me and it is.
But then there's this middle ground
where I'm like not,
it feels like this group is large enough
for me to go into performance mode,
but I don't feel comfortable
going into performance mode.
So I'm staying in this
sort of more intimate,
I'm in an intimate conversation mode,
but now I have to speak in a way
that addresses more than 12 people.
And it puts the robot inside me
that is two modes is like,
which mode do we assume?
And I don't know what to do,
and I think it just
makes me uncomfortable.
I don't have a medium sized group mode
that I have like fallen into.
I'm either performing
and you're supposed to look at me
and you're supposed to listen
to the things I'm saying,
or I'm just kind of hanging out
and I'm sort of like just a person
that's just talking to other people.
In the middle is where
things break down for me.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out
if I can relate to any
of this specifically.
I don't, and I don't know,
I don't know if I do.
I definitely, I do have a
sense of social anxiety,
but it's always this, like for me,
it's the expectation.
It's not being in the mix.
It's leading up to it.
And it has to do with
things like, am I late?
Have I forgotten what day this is?
Am I late?
Have I synced my notes?
Am I way too early?
You know, that type of thing.
Is DJ Dope Nuts a good name or a bad name?
Yeah, I mean, sometimes you gotta say it,
you gotta say it really 100 times.
Every name. Cheese Prophet.
Cheese Prophet.
You know.
So is it profit as in like
making money off of cheese?
Or a prophet making
proclamations about cheese?
I hope it's the proclamations.
Making proclamations, yeah.
Okay.
You know what, if there's 12 people.
Okay, if you go to dinner,
for some reason it never happens at dinner
because what happens at a dinner table is-
You have a zone.
You talk to the people in your zone,
unless it's a private room
and we're all going around,
then it can become, then those dinners.
That's what happened at
that Thanksgiving thing.
It seems like you don't really
like the going around the table thing,
going around the circle.
No, no, no, no.
I'm using that because what it does
is it highlights the specific dynamic
I'm uncomfortable with.
All the attention from a
group of 12 to 18 people,
or let's go 12 to 30.
Well, I wouldn't say 30,
'cause then you're getting classroom size,
and I always loved being a class clown.
I didn't have social anxiety.
It's like 12 to 20.
Okay.
12 to 20 people.
And if you're speaking,
everyone is looking at
you and looking to you,
and then that's when I don't know,
should I go into performance mode?
You know, should I let these people
know what I'm capable of?
You know?
Or should I just be a normal guy
who's just being honest?
I get that.
And I struggle between,
like, what groove do you fall in?
I relate to that.
Because the guy who's just-
Being honest
and isn't trying to be funny
or perform or impress you in any way-
Well, but maybe a little funny.
He's not trying to entertain you.
But the me that's trying to entertain you,
I'm super comfortable there.
I actually don't feel like one is less me
and one is more me.
I get that.
It's just a mode for a setting.
Next one on my list.
Oh, you ready to move on, DJ Prophet?
Prophet Cheese.
Well, we got so many.
No, it's fine.
It was just a funny way to move on.
I mean-
I was done. Go ahead.
Can I give my?
Were you done?
I mean, that seemed like-
I was done.
I was done, it was just
a little bit of a hard.
As a guy who's an inspiring DJ,
I would say it was a little
bit of a jarring transition.
Your thing is supposed to be like,
let's usher us-
Smooth, smooth,
smooth, smooth, smooth.
Into the next thing.
So it's just something to work on.
Thank you.
Once you get your DJ name,
I'm sure it'll all work itself out.
Whatever it is, I can guarantee
no one's gonna be happy with it at first.
Yeah, that's a good name.
Right?
That's a good name.
'Cause I think I've already picked it out.
Okay.
From the list.
But I wanted to keep the list
so I could always say,
these are the ones that
I almost went with,
so I'm glad I got it back.
Are you gonna focus group
this amongst like me?
Well, I know you're not-
Or is it gonna be just like-
I don't, I'm debating that.
I don't know.
I really don't know yet.
Okay. All right.
It's just too early to tell.
All right.
I don't have to be in the
focus group, I'm just saying.
I don't-
I could be a focus group.
All right, I'll be honest,
Dope Nuts was Christy's idea,
which, you know, kind of puts
it in a new light, right?
Oh, wow. Okay.
I know, right?
Kind of, you know,
kinda a compliment.
I like it more.
I'm afraid of cutting my dog's toenails.
Oh, you can't catch me doing that.
I had a fear of getting my
own toenails cut as a child,
and you know, my stepdad
had to hold me down
by the ankles so that my
mom could trim my toenails,
and it was just, it made it a lot worse.
Did he sit on you?
No, he just-
Was he sitting on you
and then holding your
ankles out in front of him?
He just kind of grabbed my ankles.
Okay.
I mean, that made it traumatic,
but I mean, what else were they gonna do?
Put me under?
You know, take me to a groomer.
How old are we talking?
You know, I'm not being.
I don't know. Early memory.
I mean, still, I still
might have been six.
I don't know.
I'm not faulting them at all.
I think that it's like,
at a certain point,
you gotta cut the toenails, I mean.
I think you can send 'em out
and have 'em run around
and they naturally wear themselves down.
Yeah, like on the concrete.
At least with dogs.
I try to take Jasper for a walk-
I don't know if you can
do that with children.
He's this freaking nail that's like,
I guess it's the thumb.
The thumb nail.
It's way up here, like, it's not,
it's way far away from
the rest of the paws,
and that toenail will curl up
in a complete circle if you don't cut it.
Yeah, it's back from when
dogs had opposable thumbs.
And it's very loose.
It feels like I could grab-
Wolves.
That toe,
like little vestigial toe and the nail
and just like pull the whole thing off-
Oh but don't.
And there's a little bit
of a bone in it.
But don't, don't.
There's a little bit of a bone in it
and it just feels like it's not attached.
What is it from though, for real?
It grosses me out.
Like what was it, what
did it do at some point?
I think I'm afraid that
you cut 'em too close,
and I think I was just afraid of.
And I was probably really wiggly
and I did get some blood drawn.
Oh, I was saying, what is that thumb?
Oh, I thought you were-
What's the point of it?
Obviously it's there for a reason.
No.
It used to be a thumb.
It's nothing now.
What I'm saying,
it's vestigial.
It was there for a reason.
So dogs had thumbs
or the ancestors of dogs had thumbs
that they did stuff with it,
open cans and stuff?
Yeah, they have a fifth,
they have a fifth metatarsal.
But why did it move up?
Because they didn't need it.
It's just like-
They were like,
we can run fast without this thing.
And then it goes away.
Jasper has them on all four legs,
but Jade only has them
on the front two legs.
And future dogs won't have 'em at all.
Jade doesn't have them
on her back legs at all.
Isn't that wild?
Yeah, and then you know,
by the time that our dogs
evolve, they'll be hooves.
It'll just be one leg.
Dogs aren't really
evolving because we're
doing it artificially.
I know, I was just saying hypothetically.
So, and then whenever I snap
the thing to cut their nails,
Jasper yelps, even though it doesn't hurt.
It's just the idea.
'Cause he's just like
me and I feel for him.
But I don't like sending
my dogs to the groomer
'cause they smell a lot
better when I wash 'em myself,
and it's like a special thing we have.
So I don't wanna send
the dog to the groomer
just to get their nails trimmed.
Sean, we would take him
to the groomer to get
his toenails cut and he-
Along with being groomed.
Right, and he bit the freaking-
He bit the groomer,
so he's not allowed to go
to the groomer anymore.
Yeah, so now you're in my boat, man.
Don't bring him me 'cause
that's what I'm afraid of.
I think I'm gonna let him run.
I'm afraid of cutting toenails.
I'm not afraid of cutting my own toenails,
for the record.
Oh, you got over that.
I got over that.
Yeah, when you're in control
of it, it's way easier.
I'd much rather cut my own toenails.
I got a pedicure at one time because-
Oh yeah.
Jessie was like-
It triggered me, man.
"You've gotta try it."
And I was like-
Yes, that brought it all back.
I went to-
I was like,
"What part of this do you enjoy?
This is torture."
It's ticklish, I'm
laughing the whole time.
I didn't laugh at all.
I mean, my toenails-
I cried inside.
You gotta get, like,
they bring out special extra tools
to get through my toenails.
You know, like, oh, we
were not prepared for this.
Bring out the Wahl system, you know,
Wahl with a H.
I saw, I think it was a TikTok
of this like feisty
chihuahua put in a sling.
Picture like a hammock type sling,
and there's four holes
where the legs go through.
And he's just like
growling the whole time.
And he's like growling
and like trying to get
to him and they're just-
But he could do nothing.
Yeah, and then they're just cutting
the toenails.
He's helpless.
And it's like, it's good for everybody.
They should put you in one of
those at the pedicure place.
It's like-
My feet are coming out of that.
I'm growling the whole time.
It's like you're right
there in the middle.
Barking at the lady.
What are you afraid of?
I'm afraid of snakes, and this has gotten,
I realized recently that this is-
God, I'm afraid of snakes too, I can't.
Yeah, I'll put it on my list, obviously.
It's affected me deeply and okay.
But do you hold the?
No, let me-
On the show,
I'm a lot more afraid
of snakes than you are.
This is a weird complex fear,
and let me, I'll elucidate.
Number one.
'Cause you hold Craig.
I'm not afraid of a snake,
I'm not afraid of.
If I know a snake is there,
I'm going up to a cage,
somebody hands me a snake,
I'm not, I'm a little bit scared
the whole time that like,
even holding Craig that like,
I've seen those videos
where they just reach up and bite you,
and their little teeth mark
get all over your face and stuff
and you bleed like crazy.
I don't like the idea of that,
and so I'm a little bit
scared the whole time,
but not too scared to touch 'em.
And I have had a recurring
dream for many years,
haven't had it that recently
where I'm walking
through some environment,
usually tall grass, and
there's snakes everywhere.
And this ties into the way
my fear has manifested
itself in real life.
Now, growing up in North Carolina,
we spent a lot of time in the woods,
next to the river, next to the creek.
We would walk indiscriminately
through the woods
without ever thinking about snakes,
and you know what, we saw snakes.
We'd be swimming in the river
and we'd look over and there'd be like,
I remember down in Keith Hills
at the bottom of that last spillway,
there was a bed of, I think
it was probably water snakes.
I don't think it was moccasins.
But like I'm talking 40 snakes
slithering on top of each other
like "Indiana Jones."
Total "Indiana Jones."
And we would like stick a
golf club in there and like-
And they were long.
They were big.
They could have been six foot long, easy.
And I stepped on a water moccasin
one time when moving the
canoe and jumped away,
and he didn't bite me.
But what I have found is that
I cannot enjoy hiking in California.
Really?
I can't-
Because of rattlesnakes?
Yes.
But then I went back to
North Carolina last year
and was walking through
the woods with Jessie,
and I realized I was constantly
thinking about snakes.
Really?
And I was like in this super focused,
like looking around and being
like, don't step on a snake.
Don't sneak up on a snake.
And I'm like, why am I,
why has this fear manifested itself?
Now, hiking in California,
when you go up in the mountains,
over the summer I went
hiking four times in a row,
I saw a rattlesnake.
Like four hikes in a
row, I saw a rattlesnake.
But they are reclusive
and you gotta really get 'em cornered
for them to do anything to you.
There was one that had its head like-
And the rattle will warn you.
On the trail, and the rest of its body,
which was weird in like
an ambush situation,
but he kind of slithered away.
I don't know why this has,
I don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened to me.
I don't think about,
I'm so afraid of snakes
and when I go hiking,
I just do not think about that,
'cause I wanna enjoy hiking.
Well, I wanna enjoy it too,
but I'm thinking about snakes.
I think my level of compartmentalization
is like super human.
I think that might be my superpower.
Oh.
What if you were called
DJ Compartmentalizer?
Or just The Compartmentalizer.
Actually, that sounds like a show on ABC,
that like stars a teenager.
You know, like a teenager
doing an adult job.
Solving-
Who like talks directly to an angel.
He has to be solving crimes though.
Yeah.
But he's like, he's doing it through
his expertise in like storage equipment.
Yeah, he just owns a storage facility.
The Compartmentalizer.
I'm afraid of snakes too, man.
I'm afraid of spiders.
I'm afraid of bugs.
I'm afraid of lizards.
I'm afraid of any little thing
that like creeps or crawls
or has multiple legs.
Multiple legs.
I had a lizard drop the tail on me.
He dropped the tail?
You know how if they panic,
they can just drop their tail,
so it'll start squiggling around
and they run away from it.
Just separate from their tail?
They have an ability
to snap their tail off.
This was, you know those-
I didn't know they could snap it off.
I thought it had to be pulled off.
Well, I don't exactly know the mechanics,
but I've always, here's what happened.
I was in the garage,
and I had just cleaned the garage.
I was very proud of myself,
and I was like, man.
And I'm like spraying like mint,
you know, you can do like mint spray
to get insects from keeping.
So you don't have to
like do like pesticides.
Oh, like ants and stuff?
Yeah, any kind of bugs, you know.
I'm like, I'm sucking up,
I'm like sucking up all kinds of,
I'm just going around and
sucking up little spiders.
And I know people don't like
it when you kill spiders,
but you know what?
I kill spiders.
If bugs get in the house, I kill 'em.
Sorry, I'm that guy, and so-
You're a maverick.
The best way to do it
is with your Shop-Vac.
Just suck 'em right up.
Yeah, surely, they probably die
slowly inside of the Shop-Vac,
but I also don't care.
I bet there's a lot to eat in there.
And so I think they make
a little community of friends
before they all die slowly.
But I suck 'em up in the thing.
Just reverse it and just blow it
into your neighbor's yard.
That's what a Shop-Vac can do.
I care about my neighbor
more than I care about the community
of insects that live inside my Shop-Vac.
Here's the thing, I was looking
at my amazing, immaculate garage
and then all of a sudden,
I saw one of those lizards
and it was a big daddy.
Sometimes they get real big.
And he was doing the thing
where as soon as he
saw me, he played dead.
Now, let me be clear,
I don't kill lizards.
It's just-
Are you fine with picking 'em up?
Nope, I don't.
Me neither.
As a teen-
I don't pick up a lizard.
As a teen and younger,
I killed lizards, I killed snakes.
I mean, I killed squirrels
and rabbits too with my BB gun.
I was a little terror.
And we did eat them sometimes
when we could convince my mom
to cook like a rabbit in the house,
which we did one time.
She like braised a damn rabbit.
You bringing a little.
Did you bring the tail
of the lizard to Jessie
and ask her to cook it?
No, I didn't.
So this thing's staring at you and then-
But I don't kill any animals
other than insects now.
I have evolved.
Okay. It's playing dead.
It's playing dead but I like,
I can't, I'm not gonna touch this thing,
'cause they bite, man.
They bite and I'm scared of 'em.
They look like a snake with legs.
And so I got the broom.
He was not even responding to the broom.
He was like, I'm so committed to this.
Oh, wow.
But then like the third
stroke of the broom,
he woke up, panicked, and went right back
into the little crevice area
where the other broom was.
Just leave him alone.
And I was like, no, no, no, no,
'cause now when I'm coming down here
in the morning to do my stretches,
I know that you're hiding over there
and you're gonna run up
and bite me on the nose
or something worse.
He wouldn't have stayed there.
And so I took the back end of the broom
and started poking back there,
trying to get him to move.
And he is like, I see him
and I'm not trying to poke him.
I'm trying to scare him-
Flush him out.
To get him outta the garage.
He does a maneuver and
then all of a sudden, bam,
I'm looking in two different places
because he's done his thing.
The tail broke off right at the base,
and this was a big sucker.
His tail was three inches long.
His tail breaks off
and begins to do this
acrobatic dance that is,
you know what?
It worked.
Oh my god.
This is horrifying.
I'm focused on this.
This evolutionary adaptation worked
because I didn't see where he went.
I was too focused on the trick.
And that thing moved-
When it detaches,
it just keeps wriggling.
For three to four minutes.
Wow.
Three to four minutes,
and then I was afraid to touch it.
I left it there for a day
'cause I didn't have a Kleenex.
That is so disturbing.
And you know what, I know that like,
what other animals?
I mean, I'm afraid of
all those little things.
What else?
I know that you're afraid of bees.
I'm not afraid of bees.
I'm not afraid, I don't know what it is.
I'm not afraid.
I just believe I am not gonna get stung
by like a yellow jacket,
a bee, especially a bee.
I am not afraid of bees.
What about a wasp?
I'm not gonna sit there
and eat lunch with a wasp.
They're demonic.
I'm not gonna mess with a wasp,
but like a bee or a yellow jacket even,
like those little yellow jackets
that come around your food,
but they don't sting you, man.
You can't handle it.
Hold on.
The little ones, that's different.
You can't handle-
A real yellow jacket
will sting you and I've
been stung multiple times.
I know, I'm talking
about the little things,
the little ones that aren't
actually yellow jackets.
I'm not scared of those.
But they're yellow.
Yes, you are, and you're afraid of bees.
I am afraid of bees.
Yeah, I'm not afraid of a bee.
Now, but-
A bee can land on me and I'll keep eating.
Not to the point-
Because you don't put
that energy out there
and then the bee won't sting you.
That's not my experience, man.
And then honestly, if they do sting you-
How many times you been stung by bees?
Not that many.
No, not that many.
I've been stung by several bees.
That's because you're being erratic.
No.
You think they're interpreting?
No, no.
Yes!
I'm saying that like,
there's multiple times when-
You're threatening them.
A bee-
I'm a bee friend.
A bee landed on me-
I love bees.
And stung me with no threat.
'Cause they don't have multiple legs.
They have cute stripes.
I wish I wasn't
scared of bees, 'cause I
really believe in them.
They have arms.
They have arms, y'all.
And you're also afraid of bats.
Is that on your list?
You're deathly afraid of bats, dude.
You didn't put it on your list?
Well, it's not a comprehensive list.
We've gone through the animals, I think.
Yeah. Yeah.
Snakes, bats, bees, spiders, lizards.
Multiple legs.
I asked Lando before I
dropped him off this morning
what is he afraid of and he said,
and this was a big one for him.
He's afraid of mascots and I was like-
That's a common fear.
It's a common, I'm like,
why are you afraid of mascots?
He's like, "'Cause I know
there's a person in there."
And I'm like, "But they don't talk."
And he's like, yes, and he said,
"And their facial
expression never changes."
It's like.
It's a silent, it's so creepy.
Like, mascots are freaking creepy.
I was like, oh, you know what?
I should be afraid of mascots.
I'm gonna start being
afraid of mascot too.
That's a good cogent argument, sir.
This is what it's like
to have Link as a dad.
You come to him with a fear
and he just adopts it,
as opposed to helping you with it.
I am now afraid of mascots, man.
I find mascots creepy.
I think that if you don't find mascots
a little bit creepy,
then there's probably
something wrong with you.
Or you're a Disney adult.
But I think that you do,
most kids when confronted with a mascot
will cry hysterically,
and I think Lando's past that point.
He's not gonna, you know.
I don't know if it's the majority.
I mean, at Disney World,
no, not the majority.
I mean, when you're like,
when you're really young.
I'm saying like a mascot
that you don't recognize.
Lando is not really young.
He's 12.
No, no, I'm saying,
but he's not gonna cry at a mascot.
He just is like,
I'm not interested.
But he is not gonna cower
from a mascot at this point.
There's a little bit of cowering.
Well, maybe you gotta get a
mascot costume and find out.
Sounds like a good-
Maybe I gotta
put him in one.
That is the way that you overcome a fear
is become the thing that
you're most afraid of.
He's gonna be like the
best college mascot ever.
I'm Batman.
And he's like, "I used to
be very afraid of this."
You should be the next Batman.
The beard won't work.
Bearded Batman, not gonna happen.
Did you say what you're afraid of next?
I'm afraid of tweeting, dude.
I'm just freaking afraid of it.
There's a lot of evidence support this.
And it's like, there's
just these few times
that I will tweet and
I'm not talking about
like a retweet or like
some sort of promotion.
I'm talking about like expressing myself
and like using, thinking about things
and writing it down.
You know, I actually think
I'm afraid of writing down thoughts,
like I hate doing that.
Yeah, 'cause they get lost sometimes.
I hate writing things down.
I hate email, but I'm afraid of tweeting,
because the few times that I
take a risk, it's just like,
it just leaves everybody
scratching their head
and criticizing me.
Yeah that's the internet, right?
And I don't blame 'em.
That's the internet.
You know what?
'Cause I always learn that, you know what?
You're right.
I'm afraid of actually having
a thoughtful discourse
with the open internet.
Oh, is that what you're
intending to do sometimes?
'Cause that feels different
than the way you tweet.
It doesn't feel like this is the beginning
of a thoughtful discourse.
Some of the things you tweet
don't feel like an
invitation to discourse.
It's just like, I don't know what-
Not-
I don't know
what series of events led
to Link tweeting that.
And it's so tough.
I mean, it's so tough
to know how to, like,
there's so many things that like,
I mean, you think about all the issues
in the world and you know.
The people who care about the things
that they care about, if they like you,
they want you to also care about it.
Especially when it's
something that's like,
if it's like an issue that people
need to champion because
there needs to be change
and it's like extremely
intimidating to me.
So it's like, yeah, to take
like the serious route here,
it's like I'm really afraid.
I don't know, it's just like,
it racks my nads, man,
to like care deeply about things
but to not know how to
like do it on Twitter.
It's just like, and some of it
is the perfectionism
thing and not wanting,
you wanna be able to anticipate criticism
so you can take care of it yourself
and not let other people do it.
Like, as a perfectionist, you know,
there is this fear of criticism, you know?
So I think that's part of it.
But then just like even tweeting goofy ,
you know, is like, I feel
pretty paralyzed on that front,
and I think I'm okay with it.
You know, I think I'm just,
I don't feel like I'm
less of because I don't,
except the times when I do
and then I realize that I shouldn't.
Yeah.
Maybe I should just delete Twitter.
I like it.
I like lurking.
You probably shouldn't delete it.
I'm not gonna.
You should probably
not follow 4,000 people.
undo that at some point,
because you got a lot of, I mean,
I had to go through one time
many years ago, 'cause we-
Jenna helped me with that.
Oh, how many do you follow now?
Oh, yeah.
I helped you unfollow things, yeah.
Yeah, I don't know how many people
I'm following now.
Oh, so you reduced the amount.
I reduced the amount.
'Cause we used to like follow
everybody who followed us.
Yeah, and then some of them
were taken over by really weird accounts.
Oh.
Yeah, there was,
you were following some
really weird things.
Yeah, I think that,
I completely understand the fear,
and you're definitely not missing out
on anything by not tweeting,
and your life is probably
simpler because of it.
But because it's like a part,
it's expected to be
part of our occupation,
and that's what makes
it kind of squirrely,
especially when it gets to like,
why aren't you saying
something about this?
And if you don't,
that automatically means
you don't care about it.
That's not true.
And because I do tweet, I mean,
I go through phases where
I'll tweet a lot about stuff,
and then I go through long periods of time
when I don't tweet.
I'm currently in a relatively
active Twitter phase,
and you do get this thing where, oh, okay,
I said a couple of things about this
and so now I need to say a
couple of things about this.
And then of course, there's
another conversation
that happens on the Mythical level,
on the corporate level, right?
'Cause we're a brand
and it is part of brand responsibility,
and just part of our personal-
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we're very connected to that,
especially when it's things that,
like the stuff that I'm talking about,
I'm actually really
grateful that we have this,
we have the Mythical
account where it's like,
we are involved in saying
yes, we do want to say something and-
Well, and to be clear-
And there's a way to say
it that like, it's not,
all the pressure's not
on me to figure it out.
We have a great social-
But I agree with it.
We have a great social media team,
but the vast majority
of things that are said
when it comes to sensitive topics
or issues that are not just, hey,
go watch this thing or here's a joke.
We are very, very involved
in crafting those messages, so.
And I like that system.
And sometimes-
And it's not, hey, you do
this for me, all right.
And especially if we've taken the time
to craft a message for the main account,
and then I'll just retweet it again
'cause it's just like, hey, this is me
saying something about
this because this is me
and you saying something about this.
But mostly, you're so right
because just getting
something a little bit wrong
or even saying something
wrong unintentionally,
like, oh, I actually misinterpreted this,
or what I said could be
so easily misunderstood.
That's the internet.
Everything I say in life
can be easily misunderstood.
Yeah and yeah-
By me as I'm saying it.
Right.
Maybe you just shouldn't tweet.
It's fine.
I'll tweet and then Mythical will tweet.
You know, we don't all have to tweet.
Yeah, I know that.
I know that.
So this is a healthy fear, probably.
Well, now I have to prove you wrong.
I have a fear of getting sick.
Yeah, you do.
Or just something, you know,
or being injured in some weird way.
I'm a hypochondriac.
You've never had a big sickness.
I've never had a big sickness.
You've had some big injuries.
I've had-
Whoops.
I've had a weird collection
of annoying maladies.
So like the number of
weird things about my body
that are just inconveniences, you know.
Okay, yes, I've got psoriasis,
I have a bad back, I don't have a chin.
That's not really one of 'em.
There are multiple things
I'm not thinking of right now.
But just, in fact, I
remember going through,
like starting at my head
and going all the way through
my body and thinking about
the weird things that had happened.
Right, like your elbows
are like weird shaped.
Yeah, but also I have arthritis in them,
and that's one of the reasons that
they're shaped like that
because they're inflamed
on a regular basis.
They're not inflamed right now,
but they were inflamed in the past
and so they like swole and
they just stayed that way.
And so, and I've got this weird
shoulder thing or whatever.
It's like-
You lost sight in one eye.
Yeah, exactly.
I've had weird things happen.
Due to stress.
But nothing that is life
threatening and nothing.
The back at times becomes life altering,
and I think it is the times that
my back has been serious enough
to be life altering that I'm like, oh man.
I mean, I'll get into a car
and begin settling in to drive.
This happened the other day
when we got into a car, and
I, when we went camping.
When we went camping with Stevie,
and I was driving my FJ Cruiser,
and as you know, there's not a lot of room
in the back seat of the FJ.
They kind of forgot what
people were shaped like.
And so I had to move the front seat up
to a place where my knee
is right against the dash,
and I said to you-
Right when you got in, yeah.
If we are in a wreck,
my femur will snap immediately,
because it's like exactly the
width of this thing, right?
Or, and we know a guy growing
up that was in a wreck
and his femur went through
his hip out the back-
Oh, stop it. Stop it!
Out the back of his butt,
and he's ended up having,
as you can imagine,
serious problems for the rest of his life.
I think about these things
to too large of a degree
because I've flirted with chronic pain
and chronic inconvenience.
And then I just think about, oh man,
I'm so fortunate that I haven't
had to deal with physical
things that cause,
make you have to change your life.
You have to do things in a different way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so I just have this-
Body trauma, man.
Fear of getting sick, getting an injury.
And if I start, you know,
if I find a mole that looks weird
and then I gotta make an appointment.
I gotta make an appointment
for the dermatologist,
and then I'll be thinking
about it kind of nonstop,
like obsessing about it until I can go
and talk to a professional
and they can tell me that it's okay.
And that has gotten better.
I don't really talk much about
my hypochondria in my therapy,
but just the process of therapy
has made me better at
dealing with it, I guess.
But yeah, that's a constant fear.
And I get it, man.
If I were you, I'd be scared too.
But you don't worry about this at all.
You don't have any health fears.
No, I just have, I have this belief that,
I don't know, I just don't,
I don't believe that
something's gonna go wrong
in like a moment to moment way.
I have a belief that
like when I get cancer,
or when something really bad does happen,
I'll be like, okay,
yeah, I knew it was gonna happen.
I wasn't gonna waste.
And I didn't make a decision
to not waste my energy
not worrying about it.
I'm anxious about plenty, you know?
It's just not one of those things.
It's just not my thing, you know?
So it's like, I'm glad that's
not on my list, you know?
But it totally makes sense why with like,
you know, you have a
debilitating back injury
at a young age, and then it's like, okay.
But I also think its just-
What else is gonna happen?
Hypochondria is genetic.
You know, my mom's the same way.
And the way that you process
stuff, like knowledge.
I feel like I'm able to
like be told something
and then, again, the compartmentalization.
If I don't want that to
trickle down into like,
what are the ramifications
of that potentiality for me?
I try not to ruminate.
Well, it's not that,
I find myself not ruminating
on that type of thing.
It's just how my brain doesn't work,
so I'm good with it.
I'm good with it.
I have a couple more.
I'm not gonna mention one
because I'm cutting it.
Okay. All right.
And I'm gonna just go,
I'm gonna give a quick shout out to being
really afraid of forgetting something
really important when I'm packing.
You know, you're on your
way to the cruise ship.
I've never been on a cruise.
Or you know, you gotta drive
an hour and a half to
the freaking airport.
And it's like, man, do I have?
I boiled it down to like, you know what?
I get in the car and I start driving
and I ask everybody in
the car, including myself,
it's like, "Do you have your ID
and do you have your phone?"
If you got those two things
in modern civilization, you'll be okay.
And maybe do you have the charger
for the phone so that you don't, you know,
if you're not at a place
where you can buy one.
You got the phone, the
charger, the wallet,
and like, you know, an enema.
An enema, that's important.
You know, if you're traveling
and if you just really, you know,
that can really put a stop
to the enjoyment of your vacation,
if you know what I mean.
Uh-huh.
Or your trip.
So I'll leave you that one.
That feeling, man.
I've forgotten something, I know it!
Yeah.
Generally, it's commonly called
the fear of missing out.
FOMO!
I will say that I have a difficult-
I'm surprised.
Time.
I wouldn't say that this is debilitating
because I'm able to enjoy myself
in many different circumstances.
But I am always without
exception thinking,
if I'm doing something fun, I'm thinking,
yeah, but there's something
else that could be more fun.
That sucks, man.
You know?
And like, did I make the choice?
Is this thing that I'm doing
right now the right choice?
And this manifested itself
on the road trips that I took
with Locke this past year,
which I planned and chose the destinations
and the attractions that we would stop at.
And if we were at one place,
I'm evaluating the
experience in the moment
and thinking to myself,
okay, this is pretty fun.
I'm having a good time,
but we could have gone to the other thing
that I considered going to and
I wonder if that's more fun.
And I think that this is
kind of what drives me
almost at like, you know,
a core fundamental level
is always just thinking
maybe this other thing,
maybe this other thing will be the thing
that is truly fun.
Again, I can have a great time
and enjoy myself in the moment
and I am getting better
at being like, you know.
On the road trip it was, hey,
the main thing here is that
you and Locke are getting to spend
all this time together
and you could be stopping
at the world's largest ball of yarn,
which incidentally, we didn't stop at.
Or you could be going to McDonald's
and you can enjoy each other's company
and that's the more important.
I definitely relate to like,
if I'm the one who came
up with the itinerary
or made decisions about something
that then there's like choices.
It's like, what am I missing out on?
It's like, it's on me.
But I don't find myself thinking,
what did they do?
What did so and so do this weekend?
I gotta go even though I don't, you know.
Well, and Shepherd and
I had this conversation
recently when I was taking
him to an appointment
and we had a little time
and we went in to get some coffees
from this place and they
had a macadamia nut latte.
Okay.
Macadamia nut milk latte.
And I remember we had macadamia nut milk
on the show and we had
liked it, I thought.
And he got like a regular
coffee or something
and then we're walking and he's like,
"Yeah, that seems like the kind
of thing that you would get."
And he was like, "You always
have to try something."
He says, "I like to just get the thing
that I know that I'm gonna like."
And I was like, yeah,
that is my personality.
Living in Los Angeles, you know,
tonight is date night for me and Jessie,
and we're gonna go to some restaurant
that I've never been to,
and we always like to go to a new place,
even though it increases the risk
of you not having a good dinner.
Because if you go to a place that you like
and you go back, you know
you're gonna have a good time.
But there's just something about
the unknown of maybe this will be better,
maybe it'll be different in some way,
and that ends up winning
out every single time.
And I don't, it doesn't always lend itself
to a good experience because if you-
But you had to know, man.
If you get what you want,
it's like what Shepherd said.
It's like I'm gonna, he's like,
I am gonna take the time
to drink this thing.
I'm gonna waste the time
and the calories on it.
I wanna enjoy it, you know?
So you a FOMO having MOFO.
Yeah, so I don't know.
I think there's a balance.
But I'm always thinking about it.
Don't be afraid.
Put your fears to rest.
Hopefully we've helped,
at least in commiseration.
Oh, those guys are afraid of that?
And look, they have a podcast.
Yeah, well, and next week,
we're gonna hear from you.
That's right.
We're gonna get
more specific 'cause
we're gonna be talking
about the supernatural, spooky-
Disturbing experiences.
Yeah, it might not be supernatural.
It might be like the time a guy, you know,
tried to get in your house or something.
I don't know.
We wanna hear the scary stuff.
Yeah and-
Because it's October, right?
And because it's 1-888.
♪ Earpod1 ♪
Of course, by the time this comes out,
we already have the ones
for the next episode.
But you can always call in
and let us know what you think
about what we're talking about now,
so we can play it at
the end of the episode.
Follow us on Twitter, not to see me tweet,
but to see the Mythical account
put prompts out that then you can call in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go, #EarBiscuits.
Give us a rec, man, for the road.
Oh, yeah.
I'm enjoying a book right now.
I won't say I'm reading it
because I'm listening to it.
"Shoe Dog."
It is the autobiographical story
of the founder of Nike, Phil Knight,
and it's just a fascinating classic,
you know, American entrepreneur.
I can't say that.
Does it rhyme with manure?
Yeah.
Story.
And the guy, he's a good writer.
He's like a super well educated
and well-traveled guy that
the way he frames his experiences
is very fascinating.
It's funny in places.
It's inspiring in other places.
It might end really horribly,
but I don't think it does
because Nike seems to
be pretty, pretty big.
Ha!
I haven't gotten to the end of the story,
but I think it works
out for him pretty well.
"Shoe Dog."
I just turned my phone back on, dude,
and I synced my notes
and I have a note called
P with nothing in it,
and I have a note called DJ Names
and it's got all of this in here,
and then I don't have a
note called DJ Names Too.
So all that was for nothing.
What?
I don't know. I don't know.
I got it right here, man.
I don't even know what to say.
Next week, y'all.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
This is Micah from North Alabama.
I wanted to tell you
what scares me the most,
and it's a little, I feel
like it's a little irrational.
When I was a kid, I used to be fascinated
with books about the Titanic sinking,
and I had posters and books.
Also, I was fascinated
with the Loch Ness Monster.
I realized that it was
deep bodies of water
with large things in them.
That's what actually
really scares me to death
is this kind of great unknown
and the deep water, that really.
I mean, I've got goosebumps right now.
Hey guys, my name is Lily.
I'm from Oklahoma.
Okay, I have two things.
One is pretty normal.
Dolls freak me out.
I don't know why.
I've never had any creepy experience.
They're just so freaky.
And the second thing that's a little weird
is like crabs and lobsters.
I've had multiple
nightmares where a huge crab
like crawls under my blanket,
and I wake up and I start like kicking
and it's so scary.
I don't know, they're just so freaky.
Okay, cool.
Love you guys. Bye.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
It's Ryan from Richmond, Virginia.
On my way home but I just wanted
to just finish and listen
to your latest one.
And what scares me the
most has gotta be heights.
I'm also afraid of like people
intensely smiling and staring at you.
Hi, my name is Alex Ramsey.
I'm from West Virginia.
And the thing that scares
me the most is pregnancy.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous episode
of "Ear Biscuits," click on
the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.